I've been using the iPad 10 for close to
a month now and I think a lot of you
guys that are considering buying one
need to be very careful for a few
specific reasons in this video I'm going
to give you guys my honest thoughts on
it who should be buying it and at what
price and who should absolutely avoid it
getting right into it I want to start
off with just the tablet itself without
the new keyboard accessory we'll cover
that in just a bit and I want to say
using this as a tablet here at the
office and at home it has actually been
surprisingly good in terms of multimedia
playing games and doing various apps
overall it is a great tablet when you're
looking at it by itself I absolutely
love this blue color even though I'm not
a fan of blue and I think the general
lineup Apple did a great job with the
colors they really pop compared to the
other iPads and that is great for a
consumer device now as you guys know
this is the first time the Apple gave
the base iPad a full redesign so so it's
modern it's clean it looks like the rest
of the more expensive iPad lineup and
that is great when you're buying a
tablet because you're going to keep it
for many years the front of the iPad is
very clean because now we have even
bezels all around without the touch ID
button on the bottom and we have this
touch ID that sits right here at the top
and no matter if you're holding it
vertically you can press with your right
hand or horizontally with your left it
is quite nice and then the volume
buttons also change depending on which
orientation you're holding it now one of
my favorite updates to this iPad are the
speakers previously with the ninth
generation and before we just had a
speaker on the bottom so if you're
holding it landscape you're watching
videos or movies or playing a game all
that sound is coming from their right
hand side now that's hard to show you
guys the difference over video but
here's a quick speaker comparison
compared to the previous generation
[Music]
take me somewhere unfamiliar
[Music]
the speakers are louder they have more
bass it sounds more natural and it
really is a game changer having stereo
speakers instead of just having it from
one side especially for gaming now
talking about gaming I played Call of
Duty at my house and the experience was
great the A14 has no issues keeping up
at 60 FPS the graphics look great the
size is really nice you can hear
footsteps from both sides and actually
track opponents now instead of hearing
it from the right if you want to play
games this is a great tablet to do that
at this price point and as far as
general performance and snappiness this
thing feels nice and fast I don't have
any issues with apps loading up and as
far as web browsing this thing gets 284
runs per minute which is faster than
pretty much most PCS even powerful ones
so web-based applications also are
really nice and quick the only downside
in performance that I noticed is just
some general stuttering because this
does not have promotion so if you have
an iPhone that has that or you have
another tablet you'll notice that it's
just not as smooth but if you don't have
promotion any of your devices it's going
to feel perfectly normal and great the
battery life is also really good you
should be getting at least 10 hours of
use if not more because the A14 that is
in here is actually down clocked
compared to some other devices and that
means that it uses less power so you're
not gonna have any issues with battery
life like you can with an M1 that can
suck a lot more and in terms of charging
it will charge faster than the previous
iPads because it can actually reach 25
watts so that's more than what the
included adapter will give you now it
won't hit 30 Watts like an iPad Air but
that is still an improvement and of
course we finally have a USB type-c port
on the bottom so it's easier to charge
if you have other devices and it's
easier to connect accessories as well
now in our Hands-On test we found out
that it is still stuck to USB 2.0 speeds
even though Apple gave us this new Port
which means that compared to more
expensive iPads it's going to take much
longer to transfer files onto it or off
of it and that is a major bummer but
considering most people that have been
buying this they probably aren't going
to care or they're not going to use that
Port other than to charge now there is
one more issue with this iPad that I did
notice day to day and I think a lot of
people will and that's the fact that the
display is very reflective for some
reason Apple decided to make this iPad
thicker than the iPad Air which means
they had to retool just so that the
display is not laminated now people say
that that makes it so cheaper to replace
the display if it cracks or the actual
screen itself you save the LCD and that
is true you can replace the screen much
cheaper than with the laminated display
now personally I've never cracked a
tablet display if my kids are using it I
use a case and because of that when
you're using it day to day to see way
more Reflections than an iPad Air which
we showed off in our comparison that is
a bummer and you definitely notice that
even in a room like this where it's dim
but if you're outside in a bright room
that makes it much worse and then with
that the contrast is a lot worse when
you're watching videos it is a dramatic
difference as you guys could see so if
you're somebody who thinks you might
crack the display it might be good that
it's not laminated but for the majority
of the time that you're using it you do
notice that downside and I wish Apple
did laminate it now this iPad also has a
secret weapon something that stands out
compared to all the other iPads and
those are the cameras now on the back we
have this camera which is the same on
the iPad Air and comparing it to the
previous iPad 9 which they still sell
the photos look so much better both
regular photos and also if you need to
zoom in now my kids use the cameras on
the back of these so it matters for them
I typically just use it for documents
and that's a nice upgrade now the real
difference is the camera on the front
all the other iPad pads have cameras
that are on the left hand side when
you're holding it in landscape compared
to this one where it is perfectly
centered exactly where it should be and
the mics were upgraded as well so let's
go ahead and take a listen this is the
iPad 10's front facing camera with
front-facing microphones and I'm looking
right at the center of the display and
keep in mind this is Center Stage so you
could also go in a wider View and then
many software will automatically crop if
it's just you or if you have multiple
people in the frame and this is the
previous iPad 9 sitting exactly the same
with a keyboard now I'm looking at the
same exact spot but it looks like I'm
looking way off to the side my head is
cut off as well which is very
interesting and you guys let me know
what you guys think as far as
microphones what difference you hear if
you're somebody who's going to be
FaceTiming you're going to be doing Zoom
or anything else this is the best setup
and the quality is just as good as even
a 12.9 inch iPad Pro but the positioning
is better now the only downside is
Apple's new keyboard now this thing
attaches magnetically to the bottom the
connection is crazy strong that part of
it is awesome and it's a dual design so
the back section which also magnetically
attaches it protects it and you have
this kickstand which I like because you
can adjust the angle and you can also
remove the keyboard if you just want to
prop it up if you're watching something
so overall the design is good there are
only two issues now the first issue is
that the build quality is not as good as
the magic keyboard this whole bottom
section is very flimsy it moves around
it doesn't feel as nice and when you
attach it it doesn't really hold on well
there's no magnets or at least ones that
are strong enough to hold it and in your
bag it actually can rub sideways so if
you get any dust or anything in there
that can scratch up your screen whereas
the magic keyboard is a solid all-in-one
system now I compared it in that review
if you guys want to see it you guys
could check that out out but I have two
other issues with it one issue is the
fact that we don't have any backlighting
and you don't absolutely need to have
that but the other issue is the fact
that it costs 250 dollars and I think at
that price point the build quality
should be better and we should have
backlighting it's one expensive keyboard
especially if you factor in that you can
buy the magic keyboard for 167 dollars
refurbish with a three-month return
policy that just makes this really kind
of overpriced and with that the other
major accessory is also overpriced of
course this uses the original apple
pencil back from 2015 it is very very
old tech for an iPad it's coming out
near 2023 and because Apple got rid of
that port and they're supporting this
one not the magnetically attaching apple
pencil too you can't even pair it you
have to use one of these adapters that
you purchase separately and you have to
use a cable you plug it in it's a very
janky solution and then you can finally
pair it the same thing comes up when you
need to charge it or you can charge it
from an iPhone that has a lightning Port
but still it makes no sense one that
they didn't support the apple pencil two
and two that they didn't include this
adapter in the Box I had to wait about
two weeks to get it even though I
ordered right at pre-open start I think
this adapter if they wanted to go this
method and force you to use the old one
at least it should be in the box when
you factor in shipping packaging all of
that included for people to have the
apple pencil now I was very curious
about the performance and I got to test
it out and yes it is more laggy you see
frame drops there's more delay so
because of that if you are planning to
uh use an apple pencil or to buy one it
just makes this whole thing so expensive
that it doesn't make any logical sense
now if you have it already you can buy
the adapter but buying a new one for 100
bucks with adapter included if it's new
stock I think that doesn't make sense
and the same thing with the keyboard
accessory so because of that my verdict
is if you are just buying the tablet
itself as a tablet and you want
something brand new this one is not bad
now I don't think that 450 is a good
price point 350 would have been amazing
399 would have been still pretty good
considering the limitations but you have
the new design and thankfully we've
already seen it go on sale for 399
dollars now I have links down below
where you guys could check it out or
check out the YouTube shopping feature
right over there you can check it out
there and 3.99 I think that's a price
point that I would recommend this if you
are not going to be buying additional
accessories like the apple pencil or the
keyboard because if you want things like
that you can actually pick up an iPad
Air 4 refurbished for just over 400
bucks and if you add the keyboard which
you can get for 167 you're looking at
572 dollars compared to 700 with this
iPad 10 and the keyboard by itself and
the iPad Air 4 it has better performance
has a laminated display it has better
speakers it is better in almost every
single way I'll have links to that below
as well so that's what I would buy if
you want accessories but if you don't
care about it and you just want the
tablet itself you like the colors I
think at 3.99 it's a buy so that is my
final verdict I wish Apple didn't didn't
make us use this pencil and this
keyboard is a little bit less expensive
but Apple's making everything so
expensive these days so personally what
I would do if you are a power user check
out a refurbished iPad Air 4 has the
same processor in there that would be my
suggestion but going forward when those
are not available it's still a great
tablet for regular normal use but the
pricing is just the biggest issue so you
guys let me know your thoughts would you
pick up one of these or would you
instead go for something maybe a little
bit more expensive or a refurbished
device I want to hear your guys's
opinion click that Circle above if you
guys want to subscribe check out the
comparison to the iPad Air 4 and 5. we
have a dual one right over there this is
the max and I'll see you in the next
video
[Music]